This is all Smash Jante. Alyssa Alissa Alysa Mercante. Alyssa
Merante. Alyssa Mercante. Alyssa Mercante. This has been the
best thing that's happened to my channel since. And basically
there's a bunch of like gamer people and and and incelss online
who hate her, but like lots of people hate her. She's just like
a very hateable person in like basically every single way. I
don't want to make it out like it's just incels. Like after a
long bartending shift filled with stereotypical Long Island bags
of trash, aka men. Gay men are notoriously
Uh, Discord chat was filled with racist jokes, misogynistic memes,
and homophobic hate. What do you want me to say? Misogyny is
bad, but you acting all surprised, Pikachu face, that there's
a group set up to attack people because they have wrong think
is literally what you do. You don't like men very much. You would
go on and on and on about how bad all men are non-stop. Is Dan
going to handle these ones? Edaku, spitting on you people is
enough at this point. Does he feel no solidarity? She made a
video that couldn't possibly be more entertaining to her
haters. Yeah. And basically there's a bunch of like gamer people
and and and incelss online who hate her, but like lots of people
hate her. She's just like a very hateable person in like basically
every single way. I don't want to make it out like it's just
incelss like do the actual anti-gamergate thing. But uh she had
a whole thing. She also is a massive ass. I don't know if you
remember. I don't know if you're around for it, Kelly. We had
a whole thing where we were laughing. She was like super thirsting
after Hassan and we made fun of her for that a lot. A lot a lot
a lot. Yes, she is like Brianna Woo. She's like this basically
seals it that she's like this current generation's version of
Brianna Woo. Yes. Okay. So, okay. So, she's like uh I don't know
Brianna Woo enough to know like is it well what what is the hatable
top three hatable things that don't have anything to do with
themselves? She tried suing somebody and put like all their docs
in the documentation and published that online really quickly.
Uh for defamation even though the person was basically just talking
about them. Um it's not even it wasn't real defamation. She uh
what else did she do? She's done like a lot of you know I think
the thing we were getting on her for was her like overt love
of and like sing for Hassan. Uh Becket should make some hate.
Well, I'm trying to think of like the other thing. She's just
cringe. Like she's just hyper progressive in-your-face feminist
cringe all the time. I see. Yeah. Okay. I think I can. You You'll
get it from watching this. Like, she'll have like deranged hate
here. I don't know. I don't know how Kelly's going to react to
this video. I thought it was hilarious, but we'll have to give
a quick watch. This is her just hating me gets confused. Here's
my story. Yeah, it's literally just about her reading the most
deranged she gets talking about it. I'd like to point out that
the original version of this was taken down for, you guessed
it, harassment. Oh, you're we're not I'm not giving context on
who Brianna Woo is. Rumidus, we're giving context on who Alysa
Mercant is. You probably don't know me, and if you do, it's probably
not for the right reasons. Gaming insiders say this harassment
shows just how toxic certain parts of gaming culture still are.
My name is Alyssa Marcante. I'm a freelance entertainment and
internet culture journalist based in Brooklyn, New York. In March
of 2024, I wrote a story that would forever change my life. I
didn't expect 24. What I Sweet Baby Inc. doesn't do what some
gamers think it does. No one company isn't forcing diversity
into all of your favorite video games. So, she wrote an article
defending this sweet baby company and then people accused her
of like sweeping and started going after her for different things.
And I wrote a story that would forever change.
What did they do? What did What is a Sweet Baby Inc.? I don't
uh I as I said earlier, they do DEI consulting for companies.
Basically, how do you make your game more like DI friendly, more
inclusive to different um like uh cross-sections of Oh, so they're
just they're consulting, not like the the end that makes anything
or really makes decisions. Um I think they do I think they do
make some stuff and put it in these games too potentially, but
I think it was mostly consulting on like how you could do it.
I think they do make assets and stuff, but I I forget exactly.
That'd be weird. The company consults on game narratives during
development and promotes gender and racial diversity in development
teams, including correct and consistent pay, training, and credits.
Blue Baby's stated goal is to ensure characters from different
demographic groups are not only added for nominal presence, but
that their portrayal is respectful. But what this ended up turning
into was uh basically games would get like 95% done and then
they'd hire this company and this company would come in and like
shoehorn in a bunch of stuff and it just didn't fit. And it ended
up being like quite representation in a lot of games that they
were forcing it into. like it felt like it was just tacked on
to totally virtue signal and it turned out that that's exactly
what it was. I would not be surprised at that. Um but also I
would probably criticize them for bringing them in at the end.
Like if you're going to have like bring in consultants, aren't
you supposed to do it sort of during like the planning phase
of things, not like when everything's nearly done. That's going
to things up, isn't it? You you want them in there before like
when when pre-production is going on, right? I think Yeah. I'm
going to say that almost none of this really matters. Like I'll
give you the information, but almost none of this actually matters
for like this video.
What I would say is also if you want to completely ignore these
companies or only take the bits out of what they've said when
you're they're consulting with you, you can if you get them on
earlier. Yeah. Right. You can just be like, "Oh, yeah. We'll
take that into consideration and just ignore this the stupid
or whatever." I don't know. But that's kind of odd that they
just gave them cart blanch like near the end of a production.
I don't know. It's very strange. Some people will actually know
how this went and we'll see how it goes. It looks like seconds
about to wind up and get quite riled about this. Remember, sweet
baby threatened and extorted people cancellation. Uh maybe they
did. That sounds like something they would have done. Like, hey,
you haven't hired our company. We're going to talk about how
you refuse to have DI in your game. Yeah, it sounds like something
they might have done. Again, I don't super care cuz it's like
actually not relevant to this video, but if we want to do a deep
dive on this or something, we can. I'm I'm happy to have the
context now. I just wanna I just want to watch this woman read
her deranged hate mail so that I can laugh at it. That's basically
allins for this segment. We go hard. Uh we could do callins after
the segment if you guys want to call in and talk about this,
but we should watch this first. You know, we're 30 seconds into
the video. Okay.
I'm a freelance entertainment and internet culture journalist
based in Brooklyn, New York. In March 2024, I wrote a story that
would forever change my life. I didn't expect it to. It was just
a report dispelling a conspiracy theory that had gained traction
in the dank caves of the internet in the same spaces where people
convince themselves that furniture sites are trafficking children
or that there's a ring of Satan worshiping cannibals in Washington
DC. That was such a weird rumor. The Wayfair kids traffic. What
was that about? Why? We're definitely not going into that at
all. But um just pointing out that this is a part of the reason
that people hate her. Yeah. Yeah, there's a part of the reason
why people hate her is because instead of actually engaging with
any of the criticism about the things she said or the things
she's done, she's gone, well, I wrote this piece and it was just
because like QAnon tier conspiracy theorist crazies on the internet
were like were like making things up about this company. And
it's like that's literally not what happened at all. But but
she's just going to like she's totally like making um she's like
trying to draw a connection between people so she doesn't have
she's doing the webbing thing, right? just 100% doing the webbing
thing. The story laid out the core tenants of this particular
conspiracy theory that a single video game consultancy firm known
as Sweet Baby Inc., led by a black Canadian woman, was forcibly
injecting diversity into some of the video game industry's biggest
titles. The report stated that a consultant working at the time
with Sweet Baby, Inc. discovered a 100 person strong curation
page on the video game marketplace site Steam dedicated to tracking
any games that the firm had worked on. The curation page also
had an affiliated Discord group, an online messaging. DEI
detected, opinion rejected. The service commonly used in the
video game industry with about 2,000 members. The Discord chat
was filled with racist jokes, misogynistic memes, and homophobic
hate. My report contained interviews both with employees of Sweet
Baby Inc. and with a
measures like this continuing to exist, but I can't get my account
back. We're saying like, "Hey, it's not cool when people post
my underage pictures."
Speak Discord.
Sure. Let's see here. In it members shared posts referencing
feminist frequency founder Anita Sarkeesian Marcus Aurelius quotes
and pictures of idealized female bodies in games. One image showed
several pictures of the protagonist Eve from Korean developer
Shiftup's upcoming action game stellar blade juxtaposed against
female characters from Overwatch for spoken and life is strange.
Embrace tradition reject modernity is emlazed on the collage.
Uh how do discords like that continue to exist? I don't know.
Sounds like my discord or about every other gaming discord that
actually exists. None of that sounds deranged. None of that sounds
crazy. None of that sounds like how she describes it. Hold on.
Listen. Listen. Messaging service commonly used in the video
game industry with about 2,000 members. The Discord chat was
filled with racist jokes, misogynistic memes, and homophobic
hate. Okay. Other than that last one, okay, the first two, I
don't know. That applies to any Discord I've ever been in. So,
report contain interviews both with employees of Sweet Baby Inc.
and with a few members of that Discord group. It's something
that I remain proud of more than 365 days after it published,
but it forever changed my life. These are the kinds of messages
I received immediately after publishing that piece. Hang yourself,
traitor.
What? Uh, okay. I Who is she a traitor on? What? It's an email
sent to my work. Hi, you racist. Could I kindly ask you to remove
yourself from this world? You absolute waste of air. Hope you
get gang by Muslim student. You're not a Jesus Christ. Okay,
disavow. That's That's Hold on, dude. I love that, you know.
Okay,
comment. No, we disavow. I'm sorry. I will say that this is probably
not the way you actually deal with this stuff to say like this
really bothering me. This is kind of what Brianna Woo did. And
you can do this on occasion, but then you can't be too shocked
when it amps up a little bit, right? You can still be you can
still say like this is unacceptable. I will say that no matter
how deranged the messages are that she shows, if there are real
tangible criticisms, this comes off to me very much like what
Pirate Software did where Pirate Software would post like the
craziest that gets sent to him and then you go like, "Look, there's
just nobody reasonable who's against me, right?" That's what
I don't like. I don't like when you do like the you're showing
like a 0.01% of your comments overall, which I I will admit that
these are probably a bigger chunk, not 1%, but a bigger chunk
of what gets emailed to her. I'd imagine it takes unhinged people
to email, right? But I think I think it's crazy when you try
to say this is all the criticism of me on the internet is like
these these insane people. This is what happens as Okay. Keep
seeing everywhere now. Yeah, I know. Sorry. Go ahead, Kelly.
As is anyone that is watching currently, have you ever sent a
deranged email like this to somebody? If so, what was your mind?
What was your thought process at the time? I'm just I'm just
kid. That was in your brain. That's happened a lot, but I don't
know why or what kind of person does it. Okay, I love every single
one of our Twitch viewers, but uh this does get fairly deranged
and I don't really want to risk it. So, if you could head over
to
kick.com/jk, that would be just be a beautiful, okay? It would
be really cool if you guys could head over there because this
gets really deranged and then I don't know I don't want to risk
some bad going down. Okay, so if you could head over to kick.com/jc
that would be fantastic and then we can continue the stream over
on kick only for the rest of the night. Okay, first four hours
on Twitch, last four hours over to kickon. We'll see you there
in just a little bit. I sent a deranged email to Burger King.
They still haven't fixed the walker. Okay, what are we looking
for? Looking for bot tricks so I can reset this and I will pin
the kick link over in Twitch chat. Okay, there it is over in
Twitch chat. I'll pin that. Yes, we'll leave it pinned for I
like writing things down for evidence and we will end the Twitch
stream. Okay, I love you guys. We'll see you over on kick in
just a minute. Okay, wait. Oh, well, I actually didn't finish
what I was saying. Okay. Uh, we're going to wait for them to
get over here. We had a good number of viewers over on Twitch,
too, Kelly. 54. We're getting up there. Getting way up there
over on Twitch. You love to see it. Oh, what's happening with
Emirates? Not not anything right now, Gringle, cuz we are focused
on Alysa Mercante's video where she We just watched the uh hope
you get gang by Muslims. Kind regards, Bob. The sign off gets
me. Okay. Bob. Kind regards, Bob. Cuz I'm I'm unfortunately of
bobs. Not going to lie. Yeah. I don't I don't know how much I'm
going to disavow rather than just laugh here. I do disavow like
in actuality. Okay. Oh, wait. There is a Hold on. There is a
thing though. This is going to be This is not going to be me.
Hold on. This is not going to be me, but it is a little bit related.
So, I'm just going to hold on. I found this. Specify because
currently all we have the context for is gang. Just these people
deserve. That's what they and I disavow, but it is what they
deserve. We've all We've all felt that one at at a different
time or another. We've all I've never felt that in my life. We've
all I disavow it, but you know what? Okay. Okay. Never mind.
Kelly has never Kelly has never once ever just That's me. That
was my thought. That was my That was my extraneous little thing.
Okay. Wait. Why would you have that thought? Why would you want
someone to be over any other kind of harm?
Uh, true. You know what, Kelly? The real answer. No, I can't
I can't say I've ever wanted that. Nope. Can't say that. That
would be crazy. Anyway, we're going to continue. From this world,
you absolute waste of air. Hope you get gang by Muslim. You're
not a journalist. You're with a complex. Oh, that's why Dan reached
out in solidarity, I'm guessing. Okay. You are a participant
in degenerate culture and a staple point of that. All I'm saying
is don't go planning that for Oh, also, yeah, that is another
sticking point for a lot of people. A lot of people don't like
that. I think she used to do cam work or something. She she's
like very liberated kind of deal. 40th birthday. You won't make
it to that point. Ugly begging for free. What a surprise. Senior
editor at Kotaku. Spitting on you people isn't enough at this
point. Your father raised a disgusting woman and she he should
be ashamed of himself. Alyssa Marante is next. Dumb this. You're
messing with the wrong people. You're next in line. Well, that
guy is just can't even form sentences correctly. He doesn't seem
like you'd be very scary. Dumb. Dumb. Dumb this is next. Dumb
this. You're messing with the wrong people. You're next in line
to be digitally hanged. You're next. What is that? What even
is that? How do you get digitally hanged? What the? And then
a nine gag image. Your next traitor. We make you famous. We make
you famous. We will continue. You with the wrong people. I spoke
to the team at Sweet Baby and infiltrated the Discord group rallying
against them to try and paint a clearer picture of what the is
going on. So wait, she's not even like a Sweet Baby Inc. person.
She's just the journalist who wrote the piece. Yes. Yeah. Why
the do they care about the journalist? Well, hold on. I'll I'll
explain maybe. Um, what I'm guessing happened, Kelly, is that
she had a very very specific lens on how she looked at this and
she wrote the piece in a way that sort of painted one side as
purely right and the other side as purely wrong. And the side
who was painted as purely wrong probably didn't like that very
much, I'm guessing. Does that make sense? I just don't understand
why you'd have all the vitro for the
I thought they would be mad at the company. It would make more
sense. I don't. Fair enough. Fair enough. We make you famous.
We will continue. You with the wrong people. Your time is coming
to the end. The clock. I feel like if you wanted to prove a journalist
wrong about the things that they had written, probably you shouldn't
just do all of the things that they accused you of doing. Uh
maybe. Again, big movements, lots of people. There are going
to be unhinged people. This doesn't mean that it's the entire
movement doing this, right? Seven likes, 250 posts or whatever.
I get whenever I respond to like an like I think I get stuff
like this, right? When I tweet and [__] if I tweet
anything to do with Destiny, I get like 30 people in the replies
saying like unhinged, but I just like it just happens. Like I
don't really it's just the cost of doing business. It seems like
like you're you're in like a contentious space. Yeah, there are
going to be people be people who are like that. You just ignore
most of them is how I feel about it. But doesn't mean it's like
good, just like it's going to happen. I do think it depends a
little bit on the communities that you foster and such. I do
think that certain people clearly foster that far more than others.
Um, and there are going to depend on who you make enemies of,
too. Yeah. But sometimes people just their communities aren't
based on being hateful and crazy. So, they don't really tend
to have community members that are hateful and crazy. So, I don't
know. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, your time's coming to an end. Uh, this
is just too on the nose. This is like, dude, are you not how
you're so cringe with the Joker posting? Alyssa Marante, safe
your sorry ass. Kotaku is next. Alyssa needs to be hang. And
then they sent a picture of the gallows bring no value to the
world and would be beneficial to humanity in your case since
you're too narcissistic to do that. Most parasites are I Wait,
hold on. Oh, she must have had to cut the first part. Regarding
your views on Akira Toriyama. Wait, what did she say about Akira
Toriyama? After looking at your Twitter, I found out you're the
most disgusting, ugliest piece of [__] I've seen
in a while. And I endorse for worthless, dumb, and ugly people
like you. You bring no value to the world, and would be beneficial
to humanity in your case since you're too narcissistic to do
that. also endorse going to a hood in your neighborhood and the
mob will do the same. Let's see if black gangsters are so inclusive
of pansies like you. So Mel Gibson alt account, you hate to see
it. That's up. I hope you get a packa. Why is it always a pack
by the way? That's weird. Yeah. What is the what is the preoccupation
with being by a gang of people? I don't like this is the most
derange thing I could think of. Well, this time it's black people.
The last time it was a Muslims. Mhm. Mhm. Absolutely. Know she's
probably going to get threats from all varieties of cultures
at this point. Human being either yourself or get killed. Look
at this. And it's a picture of a bullet. Here's a Oh Jesus. What
the Okay, I don't think there's technically anything to violating
there. But Jesus Christ. Don't slot. Thank for the gifted
sub. The Why did somebody make this? I assume that's that's got
to be her. Jesus Christ. of some giant humanoid creature wearing
a sweet baby ink mask. I mean, it's okay. A second. Thank you
for the five gifted. I don't know why the audio is right now,
but thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I can never fix this like
long term. Something happens with the CPU. I don't know. Whatever.
Um, okay. Humanoid creature. That's just a fat guy. What do you
mean humanoid creature? That's just a fat dude. What the Alyssa?
It's just a fat dude. Presumably because there's no discernable
face cuz they have a mask on. Yeah, but it's just a fat dude.
Despicable human being. Either yourself or get killed. Look at
this. Wait, I I said second. Thank you very much for the five
gifted. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And it's a picture of
a bullet. Here's a picture of spin boy also did say in graphic
detail how he would how open my fallopian tubes come in it and
then after I don't know if this is before or after he murdered
me and then I had an argument with him about how stupid it was
because he could not come in my fallopian tubes and how tiny
they are to cut in half and then he got mad. Uh you don't understand
how small his is. Okay, Kelly, you're not Well, that was my argument.
Either you have the most tiny m of all time or you don't understand
the physics of what you're trying to imply.
Well, yeah, he said some pretty strange things. Crazy. Wearing
a sweet baby ink mask. I will just be your pay pig. Oh my god,
it's a donation. Wilson donated $3. Ask Kelly what's worse. Packs
of blacks or packs of Muslims. No weasling out of the answer.
Give one or the other. Uh, Kelly, did you hear the donation?
Can you see the donation? No, I don't have my OBS on. No. Oh,
they said what? What would be worse? Pack- which pack would be
worse? Okay. Out of the ethnic groups suggested so far. What
do you mean pack? What what would be worse? How? Pack of pack
of blacks, pack of Muslims. Two different groups have been suggested.
What would be the worst? Why would any How the am I supposed
to know? Why would I know that? Or how could I know that? Do
you think I like I'm aware of like how groups of people gang
each other and which would be worse? How would I know? Somebody
said intuition.
Intuition? What kind of intuition? How can you have intuition
over gang? That's not something someone has like the ability
to like prepare for. I don't know what that means. Okay. I hope
subhuman beat you into a coma you then start to skin off alive
to eat you. Subhuman, weak, stupid horns like you deserve to
die screaming with black and hands beating your stupid skull
until you yourself and start seizing. Okay. Uh, this guy's the
most unhinged so far. This guy isn't even suggesting this guy
is suggesting that you will be cannibalized. I'm sorry. When
when a white woman says, it's just very funny to me. It's my
fault. I'm sorry. It's just always funny. This is the most deranged
one so far. No one is going to save you. Totally disavow that,
by the way. Totally disavow it. It's That's crazy. We don't like
these. Unfortunately, reading them out loud are It is tremendously
funny. Unfortunately, nobody should send messages like this.
If I knew that you were sending messages like this, you came
from my community, I'd ban you everywhere. Okay, just to be clear,
okay, but unfortunately, now that they're being coated and put
out in one like cohesive piece, I I am laughing. I'm sorry, but
it's it's laughing at like how psychotic it is obviously. Is
there an exception to the we don't moderate DMs rule if they
send something that's bad? Uh, no. The not in this case, no.
But okay, I'm saying if you were sending it on Well, it would
depend like if if people were doing that in any case with like
somebody reviewing for content, I would think about it. Yeah.
Yeah, I would definitely think about it. No one is going to save
you. I was getting hundreds of messages across Twitter, Instagram,
my work email, my private email, and elsewhere. Not one to have
my integrity question. It's not dark humor. It's not interesting.
Why does she have I have been up for 4 days on aderall colored
eyeshadow? Why does she have I have been up for 4 days on aderall
colored eyeshadow? I don't know. I Why would I know that, Kelly?
What's with the eyeshadow color?
Um, it's very orange. I don't know. Okay. I was getting hundreds
of messages across Twitter, Instagram, my work email, my private
email, not one to have my integrity questioned or my name smeared
or to just lay down and take it. I push back against these detractors.
At the same time, a whole host of YouTube video. See, this is
this is where I like I do feel bad for her, but like Asmin Gold
didn't say that, right? And there's an Asmin Gold video here.
So, did she like actually go and like talk to Asmin Gold or Rev
says that? Did she actually like respond to the to the things
being said in these places? Because I understand you got really
deranged people, but I don't know that that will just happen.
Began cropping up that were about me, my life, my work, and anything
else I had ever done online. They were full of harassing statements,
lielist statements, defamation, misogyny,
this is pretty rough. Homophobia, and everything else you Wait,
who is that? Statements. Is she like a who am I? Misogyny. a
homophobia. Not quite. Not quite. No. Smug Alana. Okay. Where
is most of my following? Twitter and blue sky. Probably she's
a journalist, right? Everything else you'd expect from a group
of people who use rage bait to make money on YouTube. The queen
list, the witch queen of Kotaku. Listen garbage. Oh, a lot of
the content done about her would almost certainly just be like
horrible spuring. Like not funny at all. Gaming urist crawling
prostitute biggest selfish most narcissistic on the internet.
Barnacle [__] severable [__] funny enough
is written by Alysa Mante one of the most hateful people writing
about hate. Mante wishes because God knows her herpes stained
ass. Former can girl and wannabe journalism. By giving the full
name you are subtly implying that you are encouraging your a
uh there's definitely no good people here. I've not seen a single
person whose opinion I would respect who's come up criticizing
her
to proactively dox a person. Alyssa Mercante. Alyssa Merante.
Alyssa Mercante. Alyssa Merante. Alysa Merante. Alysa Mante.
Alyssa Merante. Alyssa Mercante. Alyssa Mercante. Alyssa Mercante.
Alyssa Mercante. Alysa Mercante. Alyssa Mercant. Alyssa Mercante.
Mercante. Alyssa Mercante. Alysa Merante. Alyssa Mercante. Alyssa
Mercante. Alysa. This is all Smash J. Alyssa Alyssa Mercante
Alysa Mercante Alyssa Mercante Alysa Merante. This has been the
best thing that's happened to my channel since I do love that
there's like zero self-reflection that could happen here. It
is just, oh, these people are all totally crazy. They have zero
points. There's no reasonable there's no possible reason that
all these people could dislike me, right? There's just nothing.
I started eight years ago. So, like obviously I get that you
should be able to self-reflect, but when you've had this like
level of bombard bombardment, I don't think the average person
is like that capable of it. Are they? Uh, sure. I would agree
with you. Probably not. Quite a lot.
Alyssa. Alyssa Merante. Alyssa Mercante is obsessed with me.
And while I was facing all of this, I still Nobody's obsessed
with that guy. No, they are obsessed with each other. Her and
Smash JT are 100% obsessed with each other. Who the is that guy?
That guy you just said. This guy. Yeah, this guy. Smash JT. Is
obsessed. Is she obsessed or is she responding to his crazy?
They both They both post about each other constantly. It is like
a cycle of obsession. Yes.
Okay. Well, that's weird cuz he's quite ugly. Uh, it's not a
obsession. It's like over everything the other person says, correcting
the record on them constantly. While I was facing I understand
that, you dumbass. But why would you want to bother doing that
when someone's that ugly? Just block them and ignore. That face
is gross. Mante is obsessed with me. And while I was facing all
of this, I still did my job. I continued reporting on important
issues in the space, managing a team of writers, mentoring younger
industry members, and even putting on an all-day fundraiser on
Twitch for Trans Lifeline that raised $25,000.
I kept finding more information about how horrific this charity
really is. JT brought this up. Trans Lifeline. This is the I
guess charity that she raised money for. She raised $20,000 to
a very suspect charity. Trans Lifeline has a 97% rating on Charity
Navigator and is a 5013C. Can you imagine doing your job? believe
it's uh uh actually I believe it's a 501c3 not
3C C3 navigator and is a 5013C. Can you imag Oh my god, she's
wrong. I was going to say I was going to say something crazy
but um she's wrong. Okay, she's wrong. Doing your job while getting
stuff like this daily. I absolutely promise you you will give
up before anybody over here gives up. Alysa M. The chick that
came to uphan to Hassan at a live event. Yes, when we all laughed.
If somebody has that clip of like me and Rei and Cherry and Quean
laughing at this, it would be funny. Is it narcissist and most
likely trolling for attention? We are going to be able to very
quickly escalate these things if she wants to go down that path.
She craves the attention. I would rather do time in jail after
obviously Alyssa loves me. Okay, that was do time in jail. Wait,
what the why is Wick There's Wick and then Alyssa and somebody
else. That wasn't Wick saying it though. It was one of these
guys. One of these guys up here says, "I would rather do time
in jail." Jesus Christ. Obviously Alyssa loves the attention.
Melissa Merante is obsessed with me. She's crush on me, bro.
She wants some of the 8 in Eric. She loves the uh
ion looking men in my life. This harassment deep down she loves
when people talk about her. Creatures like mante do not leave.
They have to be pushed and she's like, "Oh, I'm a victim now.
He's saying I'm a murderer and oh my god, the trauma that I went
through." Imagine knowing your boss, your co-workers, your peers,
your friends, and your family are also getting messages like
this simply because they're associated. Oh, yeah. That sucks.
I feel like that bit particularly sucks. It's like one thing
when people are just being demented online and sending you emails
and it's like now I've got to explain all of this to like random
people in my life. It's like yay.
Yeah. You should never ever reach out to people who are around
people. Yeah. The the what do you call it? The um Yeah. That
whole thing. Yeah. Somebody decided to um buy the was itante
is her sister's
Uh.com. Somebody got this domain and began emailing her sister
from it. I just think that is hilarious. Apparently, her sister
has been hacked or taken over or domain has been purchased and
now used to harass her. Can't help but look at the situation
and laugh. I'd go and punch her mother in the stomach. Harassment
is so funny. Well, I guess it would have to be when you look
like that. So, why else do you have to do the time? Somebody
hurt her. Whether it was her parents, whether it was her dad,
whether it was a boyfriend or a girlfriend, boyfriend trauma.
Ironically, she's not a lesbian and has a boyfriend. Imagine
sleeping with this cre. I will say I will say, okay, just to
put put this out there, I feel like a lot of people do these
exact same attacks on Kelly. And I just want you to know that
that's the level your brain operates at if you do this kind of
same thing to Kelly, right? Like you're literally operating at
like the Smash JT level. you should consider, you know, you don't
have the spark, you don't have the slice of divinity in you that
you're that should be required for you to, you know, operate
on this earth. Think about think about it. Okay? Think about
considering the impact you have on humanity. Yes. Okay. Think
about it. And think about learning what irony means. That's very
important. Okay? Not being not a lesbian is not ironic. You want
me to hit play, Kelly? The boyfriend. Imagine sleeping with this
creature. Imagine being her parent. Like I've failed as a father
if if my daughter acted like this. When I decided it was time
to take legal action against those who were smearing my name.
Alyssa Mercante who sells herself for and sucks for money. The
natural he just said the same thing twice again. That's the level
some of these people are operating on. Okay. She she sells herself
for and sucks for money or the other way around. I can't even
remember. But like that's the level. Okay. Habitat is on her
knees, ladies and gentlemen, who has since come forward saying
that she used to be a worker sucking for money. A senior editor
is a former prostitute. Apparently, words are dehumanizing, but
getting railed by Tyrone and his entire gang over in Brooklyn
is not. Melissa M. Dude, I every time I hear somebody bring up
like uh like black black gang, I just assume that person is like
BWO like 100%. They're just like they've literally got a tattoo
and they don't want to let anybody know. I That's They're obsessed
with like black people. Black people having sex. Yeah. Obsessed
with being like every single time. Like if that's where your
head goes, I'm sorry. That is like fetish. That is 100. Yes.
It's a fetish. Yes. That's 100% what I think every time when
people when that's like the first place people go, I will laugh
at it. Point it out every single time. It's just I would assume
not necessarily that, but it's a degradation fetish. If you're
constantly like sending threats of like, "I hope you get gang
raped." You're just sort of describing like a really humiliating
and cruel experience you want someone. They're usually into degradation
and that's not good and gross. Yeah. And possibly racist, too.
I don't know. Hard to say. Hard to say. by Tyrone and his entire
gang over in Brooklyn is not Melissa Merante sucks more at journalism
than she did sucking stinking digital prostitute those who dude
this guy it brother this guy stinks this guy sucks do you have
anything other to say other than she sucks this is you found
out about this and you're like finally I have something to say
about her she sucks
Mante sucks more at journalism Then she did
sucking like it's so lazy digital prostitute. Those who wanted
me to not just lose the job I had but to never get a job in this
space again. What do you think happened? Alyssa Mercante has
filed a lawsuit with me. It's a very frivolous 54page attempt
at doxing me and attacking me. But she admits to bringing it
on herself. Like she could easily walk away, but she decides
to no. She's addicted to this in a just world sending someone.
Uh Merkante does suck in like literally every possible way. She
really sucks in like every way. I just want to make it clear
a lot of the people around her also suck really bad. There's
like a a whole content cycle that exists of these people who
all just suck horribly. Cease and desist and then filing a lawsuit
to get them to stop harassing and defaming you should get them
to stop. But instead, Jeff kept making content and I kept getting
harassment every time he did it. He knows that though. She I
if I'm not Am I insane? I could have sworn she made content on
him going back the other way. Am I crazy? That's why he does
it. Before you even start typing what you're talking about, you're
pushing. This has been the best thing that's happened to my channel.
How would you feel if you faced this every day for more than
a year just for doing your job and for daring to push back against
people who hate you? Again, I feel like we could go read that
Sweet Baby Inc. article she wrote and there probably would be
a lot of inaccuracies in there. I guarantee you she was taking
a side in that article 100%. Right. She's saying, "I just I was
just doing my job." Well, unfortunately, you were not doing your
job in a way that was unimpeachable. I just It's again, as somebody
pointed out earlier, it's the missing missing reasons thing,
right? Like like she's just she's clearly missed something entirely.
Oh, that's the end of the video, by the way. Just for doing your
job. Did she engage with any with any criticism that wasn't deranged?
Uh, we would have to go look for that. Let's just watch the end
of the video. And for daring to push back against people who
hate you for it. Wow. That's all she did. She only only ever
pushed back against people who hated her for no reason. Wow.
To some extent she did. Well, I Yeah, it's both. See bestin.
I'm just saying that like if that article was actually like uh
what do you call it? That article was totally well done and wasn't
like kind of just trying to paint those people as like uh Gamergate
2.0 know and and like malign that that server or whatever cuz
I looked at like the Aurelius quotes. Why is that bothering people?
I don't know. There's it's fine. It's fine. I mean, yes. Conversely
though, like hating someone because of a article is also pretty
weird. Like, why do you care? Just don't read it. You're giving
her more views to her article. If it sucks, just ignore her.
Yeah, I would have covered her Sabra Hummus article. Man, I'd
love I I don't know where my coverage of this would be, but like
I wonder if I covered this. I covered a lot of her stuff around
some of her stuff around this. I do wonder where it would be
because I my remembrance was I never once thought this panel
was like really that bad. I'd love to see how I reacted cuz I'm
sure Alysa Merante writing about this panel would have changed
my mind a little bit or would have like pushed me in a direction
for sure. I don't know if I reacted to this exact article or
not. Interesting. Why make content on someone you dislike? Why
not? It's fun. This article causes damage in communities we care
about. I guess I don't know if it caused damages in community
damage in communities I care about, but could could be. I think
there's I mean there's a difference between making content on
someone you dislike because you want to like criticize the thing
that they've done, you know, and then there is just sitting around
calling her a ugly cam that should get or whatever, right? Yeah.
Nobody, nobody that like literally nobodyows that. None of even
the people who like even all those unhinged people who were there
and like talking about her a lot. Basically all of those people
except maybe like the guy who said she wants her to die like
he'd want to kill her or something. Other than that guy, I think
all of those people just disavow, right? Sure. But I don't think
any of them were giving real criticism either. It was just a
lot of spuring. Right. And I don't know necessarily that those
types of YouTubers do care about giving sort of critical um feedback
and actual in-depth or whether they're just drama. They're just
spurs. So, I don't know. They look like the Well, I don't know
if she's into that either. I don't know. Like I don't I don't
know what she's into. She also might be the same way where she
just spurs instead of actually engaging with criticism.
Right. Well, presumably she already has the article as proof
that she's capable of writing something. Just because it sucks
doesn't mean that it's not like a comprehensive thought, but
isn't just spuring at somebody and calling them uh saying they
suck, right? Like what she's written is still, you know, a tangible
piece of work. Sure. Okay. Uh she tweeted this at Asminold today
this morning. So asoldold talks about my video on stream says
I brought all this on myself. It's then immediately flooded flooded
with harassing comments. You didn't even watch the video, Zach.
I brought up I brought and death threats on myself. Your legacy
will be more disgusting than your house. Alissa Marante made
her first edited video on YouTube and it got banned by YouTube
for bullying and harassment. You can't make this up. Okay, hold
on. Do we think that that was a legitimate ban? Or do you think
that they didn't realize when the when it automated banned her
automatically banned her? Do you think they just didn't realize
or sorry when they automatically removed the video? You think
they just didn't realize that she was criticizing people like
saying those things to her? That's 100% all that happened. The
person who made this threat is We should make a bet what will
happen first. As gold cleaning his house and it looking really
good or this woman riding a good old He's already cleaned his
house. He would have to tear his entire house down to make it
look good. That's not a fair bet. He wouldn't have to. He just
like get it done. Also, I don't know if it's still clean. He
did clean a room and move piles on top of piles. I don't know
how clean it is as in clean or if it's the whole house. Okay.
I'm not sure. Melissa Marante made Okay. This is YouTube actually
shut her down. This is the same clip. In her first real editing
video on YouTube and it got banned by YouTube for bullying and
harassment. You can't make this up. Oh man, that's just too bad,
right? This would have never happened if she didn't start doing
this. She started this whole thing herself. Let's set the record
straight, shall we? Every single Hold on. I can tell this would
I could see it with him. Well, watch, watch, watch. I can see
exactly what's going through his head here. Oh, man. That's just
too bad, right? It's just this precisely. It's just this clip.
I mean, oh no. I mean, no. Oh, no. Why have we started using
Nick Fent?
Oh, no. No. All of these clips are very old.
No. No.
That's terrible. Oh, true. We also have always done that. I hate
to see it. No, there were significant periods of time where you
didn't actually. I know cuz I've been around. I think what happened
a couple days ago was I went to my laptop and I realized I had
a whole folder full of like funny memes and then I started posting
them everywhere. So now I got some funny Is this laughing at
Sneo getting banned? Yes, it is. Oh no. Be a bit more selective
with Nick clips.
No, no. I'm It's funny. It's just funny. And if you can't handle
it being funny, that's okay. I'm fine. I'll try not to use them
when you're around being able to handle it. But also, you should
probably be careful to make sure you're not on Twitch when you're
doing them either. Uh there's literally nothing wrong with showing
non toos violative content from Twitchban creators so long as
it's not live.
You are. If you want to me to rule, you want to site me the toos
rule, that's fine. Yep. You're not a partner and you should be
more careful. Okay. Okay, you have absolutely this would have
never happened if she didn't start doing this. She started this
whole thing herself. Let's set the record straight, shall we?
Every single time we posted, we were always responding to something
she said about Asen. I'm starting a YouTube channel. Here's a
sneak. Ooh, see this is the thing where she's like, Asmin Gold's
causing harassment towards me. Peek at my first thumbnail. So,
she's going to make a video about how I smell bad. I went back
to check and this right here is the worst thing Baldi said about
her. I bet she smells worse than I do. And this is what Baldi
said on the very first clip about her sweet baby ink article.
Disagreement is not harassment. Whenever people are disagreeing
and saying you're full of that's not harassment. Nobody supports
actual harassment. And while my client's conduct has been exempted,
it would be good if people could actually just post arguments
rather than just insulting each other. So she mindlessly continued
elevating the temperature with statements such as these. And
if you have a problem with that, come fight me
because you're doing this on purpose. You are being a bully.
Didn't Can you Can you see a little bit of how that might be
annoying to some people, Kelly? Yeah, but then they probably
should just offer to fight her. I don't know. Instead of sending
she tried to take away your I think she's probably talking to
Asmin Gold sponsors for Dragons Dogma, too. I I don't know if
she did. Yes. I see I I didn't even know that. Like, and that
that's how unimportant this person is. If you take up action
against another person and you try to get this person like deplatformed,
cancelled, you deserve this. You do. You deserve this. This is
what you deserve. And uh can you watch the video that she reuploaded?
No, I'm not going to watch it. Then she's probably going to try
to DMCA me for the video. Do you think I'd actually play into
that trap? I know what people like this do. I know. Come on.
Come on. Watch it. Uh the the thing as gold. Okay. Asold's smarter
than me here, okay? He knows that he's going to watch it and
he's going to cackle and he doesn't want to get clipped cackling
at those those exact phrases. Okay, he's playing it smart on
the optics here. It's up. Know how they think. I actually have
something better. Now, this might shock you, but Alyssa is also
a huge Well, he rejected her, too. They're probably Uhoh. Oh,
man. I remember we were the first one who put these clips out.
We went and found these clips, went back, dug it up, watched.
Oh my god, this was some original original content dumpster diving
on my stream that happened.
I heard you to run. No. Yeah, we're we have we have a couple
different things that we need to infiltrate. Yeah. So, I'm sorry
for not going to pick your brain about gamers and politics.
Yeah, we can do it another time. Yeah. You can actually pinpoint
the second when his heart rips in half. You thought you were
going to escape McDonald's. No. Okay. Okay, dude. That's crazy
coming from Asmin Gold who just barely escaped McDonald's. That's
soed up from him in particular because that actually was his
future if he didn't make this work. That's crazy. All right.
Okay. I was right. So, yes, it is a day that ends in why would
Hassan. Okay. More more Hassan. Okay. Hold on. We can watch that
maybe later. For now, Alyssa Mercante. Okay, we're done with
this. What was I going to What were we going to next? Oh, somebody
really wanted us to watch Dan had a video on this and I'm wondering
I I don't know. I don't know if I want to cover Dan's stuff to
be honest with you. I don't hate Dan or anything, but uh hold
on. Some It was Zuul. Let me go find Zu's comment here where
he was linking this. He linked it like a couple
Zu9. Let me check it out. We love Dan here. I mean, we say the
line, but like I don't know if I want to watch his his content
on this. We'll see. What is it? It's pretty short. Good morning.
Been a while. I guess it's afternoon. Let's say I may not want
to watch Dan content. It is. Hassan's number one journalist Glazer
is crying foul. Oh, that's the angle he's going to take. Dude,
uh-oh. Uh-oh. Are we going to have to switch up? Are we going
to have to switch sides now? I was going to say already it's
getting difficult cuz unfortunately Alyssa has all the right
enemies and now Dan is unfortunately stepping into the ring,
right? Like I'm sorry, you watch that Alysa Mercante video and
it's like Smash JT, all of the 50-year-old Gamergate people and
uh and Asmin Gold. And I'm like, you know what? Unfortunately,
the enemy of my enemy is my friend. I don't really actually principally
hate Alyssa Mante in any way. She's just cringe. And now it's
starting to come out a little bit that like the worst human beings,
not Dan, but uh Asmin Gold, Smash JT, these people are aligning
with her, against her. And I'm like, what do we do? I won't like
her stuff, but I I'm gonna I'm might have to be a little critical.
We'll see. We'll see what Dan has to say. I wanted to do a video
today on something that's near and dear to my heart. And that's
online harassment campaigns directed at me. No, just kidding.
Directed at someone else. Oh, he's not going to like that. She
covers for Hassan all the time, is she? Okay. Okay, let me back
this up. I got to use the bathroom really quickly. I'm going
to get some water as well. I'll be right back. Hit play. Hey,
what? Good morning. Anonymous just tipped at this point. But
Dan's campaign is about anti-semitism at Twitch in the same way
Gamergate was about ethics in game journalism. Uh, no. Actually,
Gamergate was way more about ethics and game journalism than
it the Twitch stuff is about anti-semitism at Twitch. But it's
fine. That said, I uh I wanted to do a video today on something
that's near and dear to my heart, and that's online harassment
campaigns directed at me. No, just kidding. Directed at someone
else. This time, there is a former journalist, I guess, at this
point. I'm not sure. Uh, Alyssa Mercante, who made a video, which
we're going to go over. Um, and I'm going to explain who she
is, just the hate that she's received online. But before we do
that, I wanted to explain to you why am I covering this or who
this person is or why I give a because usually I don't. So Alyssa
Mercante, okay, is the number one glazer of all time of Hassan
[__] And that's an especially dangerous position
to have because Hassan [__] is a man that I am not
a fan of. Okay, is what I would say. And yeah, he's he's doing
quite a bit of damage to online by normalizing and kind of equating
anti-semitism and anti-ionism as the same. And of course, he
tries to say that he's not doing that at the same time, but realistically
speaking, he is. But enough about Hassan. Essentially, Mercante
was a
That's extremely unfair from Dan. Oh, he's using the Imager album
I had too based. Okay, that's very unfair from Dan. I think that's
like explicitly what Hassan argues against, right? And he's arguing
other people are doing it most of the time. You're the one normalizing
it. Also, what was the dono that came through? Bob Rob with the
five gifted. Let's Oh, thank you very much, Bob. Rob, thank you.
Thank you. Yeah, I just Dude, like the one thing Hassan probably
isn't doing is conflating the two, right? He actually constantly
him and Sam Cedar same page. Like that is the worst thing you
can do. And they always get mad because essentially when you
are anti-Zionist, when you're anti-Israel, you'll be accused
of anti-semitism, right? That's that's like his point. I don't
know, maybe Dan has like a more nuance point there on how it
could be conflating the two. Former journalist and maybe she
went someplace else after, but it is just nonstop backto backto
backto back thirsting for Hassan. Did we make this album? I think
we made this album. I think Crow might have made this album.
Is Crow around? I think Crow made this album. I'm pretty confident.
Which whatever. Like, I don't give a [__] That's
fine. The problem is is that this person is also a journalist
that is putting out puff pieces literally on Hassan. Um she got
called out for this. Here you see that this is one of the pieces
she did a whole Yeah, this is our this is all our unique journalism
and then uh I think at some point after watching it, you know,
on my stream I think some people got it on Facebook. No disclaimer
about how apparently she just wants to Hassan. Um, I mean that's
my opinion from reading all this stuff. Um, but I mean this Yeah,
it's very obvious. This is just beyond obscene from a quoteunquote
journalist of of what you would expect to have. And yeah, and
she's putting out this stuff. But specifically, I would say the
the main reason that I'm I hate this person is because of this.
When we had the whole TwitchCon,
uh, oh, he doesn't like the article for Zionist. that whole situation.
The fact that she felt the need not only to put kind of her spin
uh on this basically, you know, saying, "Oh, you can't say habibi,
a friend, beloved, no mention of so many of the the criticisms
against what this was." It just it just me off watching this
thing. Like, oh, that's a powerful argument, Dan. Watch this.
Watching this, it just made me mad. this guy who's I I it just
was it just rubbed me. Okay, hold on. Do you guys think Dan actually
read the article? Do you guys think he he's not actually he's
kind of just scanning? Did he actually read it the wrong way?
And then this whole piece is kind of it's just damage control
um in my opinion. So that's true. Yeah. Sorry. It's damage control
for something that was totally like uh it was a mountain out
of a molehill in the first why we're about to do this. But that
said, so this person today put out a video bemoning, is that
a word? Feel like it is bemoning the hatred that they receive
online. Okay. I think what Dan's going to do is he's going to
basically compare his harassment to hers. And I I wonder what
his advice to her is going to be because I don't think you would
really compare your harassment to hers and then say you should
ignore it because just looking into it makes people like uh focus
on it more and gets you more harassment. I don't think you can
give that advice and then also show off yours and do the victimhood
thing on your end. That would be weird if that's the way this
video goes. Uh, let's just get into it. Let's get Could I want
you to have the full scope of who this person was before we really
got into that? So, let's go. My name is Elizabeth. I'm a freelance
entertainment and internet culture journalist based in Brooklyn,
New York. In March 2024, I wrote a story that would forever change
my life. I themselves that for
that we're going to skip through until Dan cuts in because we
always obviously just already watched the video. The curation
page also had an affiliated Discord group, an online messaging
service commonly used in the video game industry with about 2,000
members. The Discord chat was filled with racist jokes, misogynistic
memes, and homophobic hate. What do you want me to say? Misogyny
is bad, but you acting all surprised, Pikachu face, that there's
a group set up to attack people because they have wrong think
is literally what you do non-stop or what you did do when you
were a journalist and when you were tweeting out like you don't
like men very much. She would go on and on and on about how bad
all men are non-stop. Here are some examples. Hold on. At all
men are nontop. Here are some examples. Ah, it's so historically
accurate. The white guy and Shogun can't help but fail upward.
I mean, that's more a like colonial thing, right? That's more
a race comment. Me after a long bartending shift filled with
stereotypical Long Island bags of trash, aka men. But I think
the sausage is very aggressive here. Okay.
Gay men are notoriously transphobic.
Uh, the man-hating thing. Okay. Why do men have rights and internet
access? There's like something more complex here happening, but
I don't necessarily think I'm going to push back against the
idea that she hates men. Seems to be fairly accurate. I don't
like the criticism. It just tends to be lazy that people who
are feminists like don't like the hate they get online, right,
to me. But it's uh if she posts about it enough,
these are the kinds of messages I received immediately after
publishing that piece. Hang yourself, traitor. It's an email
sent to my work. Hi, you racist. Could I kindly ask you to remove
yourself from this world? You absolute waste of air. Hope you
get ganged by Muslims. You're not a journalist. You're with a
complex. You are a participant in generic culture and a staple
point of that. All I'm saying is don't go planning that 40th
birthday. You won't make it to that ugly begging for free. What
a surprise. How's Dan going to handle these ones? Spitting on
you people isn't enough at this point. Does he feel no solidarity?
Is there no solidarity there? Your father raised a disgusting
woman and he should be ashamed of himself. Alissa Martant is
next. Dumb. This You're messing with the wrong people. You're
next in line to be digitally hanged. You're next traitor. We
make you famous. We will continue. You with the wrong people.
Your time is coming to the end. She made a video that couldn't
possibly be more entertaining to her haters. Yeah, realistically,
like I don't have any deranged hatred towards her. I've like
I've covered her because she's cringe, but like I don't have
deranged hatred towards her. I just think it's funny reading
how insane there are, how insane people are on the internet.
I laugh sometimes when I get messages from people. Okay. And
the clock is ticking. Alysant, say if you're sorry is next, Elizabeth
needs to be hanged. You're no value to the world and I would
be beneficial to humanity in your case. Since you're too narcissistic
to do that, most parasites are. I also endorse going to hood
in your neighborhood and the mob will do the same. Let's see
a black of some you then start humanoid creature wearing a knife
to eat you subhuman weak stupid like you deserve to die with
black okay stupid skull until you p yourself and start seizing
no one is going to save you okay that that's a really nice selection
yeah you've been muted this whole time I've not heard you talk
for quite a while Kelly sakes never mind okay sorry I just I
assume sometimes you do slip away without or I don't hear you
say anything and I'm just like okay it's fine whatever yeah if
I no worries no worries I in I installed my stream deck and I
think I must have just hit it with my foot. I hope some human
I didn't even notice it being muted. This is such an awesome
transition right here where where she reads this message and
Dan just goes okay and beat you into a coma skin off alive to
eat you. Subhuman weak stupid like you deserve to die screaming
with black hands beating your stupid skull until you poop yourself
and start seizing. No one is going to save you. Okay, that that's
a I'm sorry. It's just like, okay, I guess really nice selection
of 12 things of people insulting you. I feel like I probably
get that much a day on my DMs and whatnot. Like, here's just
the like goes publicly uh on Twitter towards me. You're so mad
about the song being taller and better looking and more popular
than you. You can just do the normal thing of budwiring yourself
instead of the sad public display. You're a loser who kneels
to destiny. Drop the ego, you freak of nature. Have you tried
not being a Dan Selman is a on child trafficker? Aren't you Aren't
you the guy that founded a website with Pdy? You support mass
Dan the be it with P Diamond. Your support will not survive as
Oh, that's some uh Oh, Jesus. Sorry, I missed that one.
Ends. I put a um the communist sickle
the triangle. There it is. I mean, oh no, this is a this is an
ad. Oh, this is an ad. It's an ad for his extension.
Got [__] up. I would guess I would say that like
this is not so I'm not going to read every one of those. No,
it's a lot of It's a lot of Wait, wait, wait, hold on, wait,
hold on. He does not There's no way. These are duplicates. These
are all duplicates. It's a duplicate and he's scanning. I mean,
it's scanning down, but it's duplicating. Wait. Oh, he didn't
do it again, did he? Like here's just the that like goes publicly
uh on Twitter towards me you maybe maybe not. Oh yeah. H there's
that one. I don't even know where this I put a um the communist
sickle the It's mostly triangle right at the end. Yeah, it's
just right at the end where it loops back. So I would guess I
would say that like this is not Oh, don't do two. Don't do two.
Don't do two. Oh, I hope you get bullied was one that I think
was going to go through. I think that's he ran it twice, but
it's okay. unique to you. Like people are gonna hate you when
you're passionate about something that other people are passionate
about and you take the other side of the issue and you're very
objective and you're very angry and you're very stuck in your
way. That's uh No, no, no, no. He ran through the whole thing
twice, but he almost got to a third time the game. Okay, we know
this.
The video is so audio desync. Alien mode reload kick. Maybe you
never knew this because you did get any gang rap threats just
out of curiosity. Uh I did not see. Do we actually have to go
through and see if he got like threats? I was just curious. I'm
curious. I'm just curious cuz like I would say Dan would probably
feel the same way like women getting threats kind of like people
getting like Holocaust jokes and stuff, right? Where it's like
oh that taps into a certain thing that might be like a more of
a fear for them than other groups. So it's a little up to use
it against them, right? You think he'd feel also there was anti-semitism.
There's about as much anti-semitism towards Mante, wasn't there?
Just the journalist that was going after people and you felt
like you didn't have to get anything back. Well, now you're a
content creator. Now that excuse is gone. You are someone that
is able to be criticized for your stupid takes uh or for your
base takes. It doesn't matter. Um that's just how it goes. When
you create content online, you are not going to please 100% of
people 100% of the time. And if you do, you're just some guy
like Tom Hanks or Keano Reeves who you know nothing about and
just exists with a very carefully curated uh PR team that puts
out nothing. But oh man, Keano Reeves, yeah, he's the best. He
bought everyone on the crew drinks. And do you know if Keo Reeves
is a Republican or Democrat? Is he pro-life or not? So if you
put your opinions out, you can be criticized for them. Sure.
No, he doesn't say it. And there's a reason why. Because the
second he says that he starts putting himself in this position
where he probably bleeds fans. You are doing this to the opposite
level and I am as well. But you have to accept what comes with
that. I was facing all of this. I still did my job. I continued
reporting on important issues in the space, managing a team of
writers, mentoring younger industry members, and even putting
on an all day fundraiser on Twitch for Trans Lifeline that raised
$25,000. So this particular thing I really hate because it's
unus I did this good thing and they still came out. It doesn't
matter. Okay. You know what? I I helped a grandmother cross the
street the other day. Who gives a Okay, I'm I'm very happy for
you that you donated. You didn't donate [__] Other
people did. Let's not act like you're doing some amazing act,
okay? You put up a GoFundMe link and other people put in money.
Take a step back there, killer. All right. You're not Mother
Teresa. Let's like you go when you want to put your money down
there and do something a little bit harder. I'll give it a little
bit more charity. But pearl clutching that you helped set up
a fundraiser that got donated to. Settle down. All right. Those
to not just vic. Wasn't she mad that people were attacking the
charity even though it was a legitimate charity? To lose the
job I had, but to never get a job in the space again. What do
you think happened in a just world? Sending someone a cease to
assist and then filing a lawsuit to get them to stop harassing
and faming you should get them to stop. But instead, Jeff kept
making content and I kept getting harassment every time he did
it. Okay. The reason that people have a problem with you mostly
is not because of your telling of stuff. It's because you present
yourself as some objective journalist who comes into stories
with the most biased viewpoint whatsoever and pushes it at every
step and ignores every piece of information that this is getting
dangerously close to a solid critique pushes against what your
narrative is. I think this is true. When you're coming out there
and you're like a virulent anti-men
anti-white guy journalist, call her a racist, Dan, what is what
is it what does it mean if she's anti-white guy? That means she's
racist. No, white guys are going to hate you as a result of that.
I mean, obviously the self-hating white guys won't, but like,
is this surprising to you? Like, uh, you're you're putting out
media that is specifically trying to tailor a world view based
around that, all the while acting like, "Guys, what are you what?
I'm just uh I'm just a native journalist." Like one of the I
think the best scenarios uh that recently happened and probably
I think the end of your time of being a journalist was your Hassan
Puff piece [__] Okay. And why is that egregious?
It's egregious because there is compilation videos of you thirsting
to be with Hassan [__] Thirsting to be with Hassan
[__] I'm not going to
Dan probably making this video for no reason other than to give
Asmin and/or Techone something to signal boost. Yeah, it's something
you can stand shoulder-to-shoulder with them on. Hassan is bad.
Link them here. But it's just it's embarrassing watching this
and then you going out and doing editorial pieces about Hassan
is what you would call not journalism. You would call that PR.
In fact, there's this famous statement. I don't know what the
everything journalism is something that people don't want you
to publish. Everything else is just PR. That's you. You are PR
for the people you like. Okay? And that's the problem is that
you're only critical of those that you hate, which is fine based,
I guess I could say, but uh you do this for a living and you
pretend and act like uh you should be held to some standard of
Walter Kronhite when you don't act like Lexer Q, hop in the waiting
room if you want. If you want to argue about this, hop in the
waiting room. But no, we don't play now. Did we say anything
about Hassan being good? You shouldn't have to defend yourself
from things you never said. Yeah, but this guy's like really
funny content, I find. So, I just told him to to hop in the Discord.
Son is bad.
That's all they do. They're just trying to bait you into saying
that. That's all they care. They don't think that you No, they're
donating a kick for me to say it. They're donating a kick. No,
I'm saying I'm saying the guy that No, I'm saying the guy that
you just responded to who wrote in kick chat. It's just saying
that so that you'll spur about how you actually don't like us
on again for like the 12th time this week. That's what they do.
Okay. That guy joins stream though. That guy that guy joins so
does Kelly who is here right now. Okay. Consider my opinion more
valuable than random Discord chatter. Sorry. Kick chatter number
38. Okay. Walter Kankite, you are I don't know how that you are
now writing in your chat. You're doing everything you used to
yell at me about. You're like, "Kelly, stop getting one guide."
And then you'd be like, "Kelly, stop writing in the chat getting
one guide." Yeah. Can you uh Hold on. If you go to the stream,
could you tell me at the end of kick.com/ What does it say there?
I thought you said you liked being reminded that you don't have
an ego. I I'm saying I'm It's not ego. I'm saying it's my stream.
If I want to do something, what is that argument other than ego?
Isn't good advice good universally? Isn't it a good advice universally
or is it only applicable to everyone that's not you? It's only
applicable only to everyone who doesn't put all of their time
into building a stream. Yes. If I feel like if I feel like certain
things are taking away from the stream, I'll I'll be annoyed
about them. And if I want to argue with this guy, that's like
literally what people are here for. So people are haven't often
been here to argue with me. You know that's not true. They mention
me more in your Discord than they mention you. Uh yeah, that's
cuz you constantly fight with them when I'm not there. Yes, you
constantly fight with them. You literally added uh who the did
you add this morning and they were like, "Oh my god, does Kelly
like get people to like send her screenshots from here? Does
she have an alt in here? Does she name search herself in here?"
Yeah, this morning. This morning people sent me messages. I don't
know about this morning. Someone just someone just asked like
this morning. They were like, "Hey, I commented on Kelly in like
this Discord." And then she responded in her Discord. Who was
it? Who who's talking about this about anything today? Are you
talking about the amaran setup? People were just talking about
the amaran stream, so I went to go watch it. They didn't even
give me a time stamp. I just went to go look. Okay. I don't know
what you're about. We are going to hop back into the Dan content.
You do this for a living and you pretend. Oh, you're such a [__]
Like uh you should be held to some standard of Walter Kankite.
Well, I mean fighting with Kelly is the right thing to do. You
know what? I am gonna listen to this random chat of the one guy
you as soon as it's okay. That is the joke. As soon as Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That was the joke. Congratulations. Yeah. Okay.
All right. When you don't act like him. Um you are not a Walter
Kankite. You are a son per you are. Stop donating. Let Kelly
speak. You walking living breathing propagandist.
You're in a hell of your own creation. She's a walking breathing
propagandist or something. Kelly, hold on. When you don't act
like him. Okay. You know what? There's like 80 like Kelly. Kelly
go off. A walking talking propagandist. Okay. Is there an issue
with biased journalism? As long as you're upfront that you have
a bias. Probably not. If she is sneaky about it, that's probably
kind of I don't know. Oh, hold on. Wait. Kelly just made an incredible
point. Wait, hold on. Didn't Dan get a whole bunch? Weren't I
getting linked like some Dan articles from like clearly like
the line groups? Wasn't that the joke that there was a DAN article
about some drama that was happening, something with Hassan? It
was like an anti-Hassan piece and we looked up the name of the
thing and it's like this is a this is like an Israel funded propaganda
arm. So Dan doesn't have a problem with this most of the time,
does he? Maybe. Actually, Dan does think I think Dan doesn't
have a problem with this. He just knows that if you have that
alignment, you are going to get hate over it. So I guess if there
were if if a journalist from one of those websites that was like
a a issues focused website if they were getting anti-semitic
hate then I guess Dan would say to them stop whining you have
to suck it up you post with a bias so you're going to get hate
right that would be his response to them it's also quite rare
to have complete objectivity in journalism I'm not entirely sure
that it exists like we we claim that it's quite good but it's
not perfect and there's examples of it not being objective at
all. So like but there is also a point where maybe bias goes
a bit too far. So I don't know it's more like the transparency
is important right more also than anything else. Okay you guys
need to chill. Stop. You are not a Walter Kronhite. You are a
son per you are a walking living breathing propagandist with
a narrative and people were upset that you were doing this in
an industry that they felt you were destroying. You're going
to get hate for that. That's what happens. The British Broadcasting
Corporation, you speds. All right. Jesus Christ. Okay. Again,
not saying I agree or disagree with any of this stuff. I'm just
trying to explain to you because it seems like you're lost why
there's hate coming your way. When you piss off a lot of people,
they're going to Oh, it was the Kenny thing hateful towards you.
And it's not like you were just doing innocuous broad NPR or
PBS style reporting. I don't even know an NPR uh or PBS reporter
because there's no reason for me to love or hate them because
it's almost like just a bland telling of the news with no spin.
Just kind of boring. Nobody cares. So, she's like a pro- feminist
journalist. She has like an anti-feminism or an anti- I guess
man bias. I don't know. It seems like a little bit it seems a
little bit over the line to say he should have done a better
job of disavowing some of the stuff cuz yeah, you can't you can't
be like, "Oh, threats are a part of the game." I don't think
you can say that. Maybe I wasn't watching closely enough. Maybe
he did disavow some of the content of them, but I don't I don't
think so. I feel like he read the one about the black people
eating her and he was just like, "Okay, nice selection of images
there, I guess." I That's a little unhinged, isn't it? I mean,
I'm unhinged, but I'm unhinged over here on kick. I'm not posting
like YouTube videos. Wait, do you guys not remember that happening
like two seconds ago? Hold on. Hey, do you guys not remember
that happening? That literally happened. What's up? Whenever
Kelly has to speak due to points redemptions, can you softly
play Willie Fi in the background? Now that's production value.
You're talking to the guy that won't fix his microphone that
goes off every time he touches it slightly. You'll manage that.
Oh, shut up. Yeah, pretty easily. If you fixed how you don't
have to be put into the intro into your eardrums.
Oh, shut up. You done? I'm done. Yes, I'm done. He never fixed
that either. And that's been a problem for like forever. cuz
there's no reason to fix it. If you're waiting to talk to me
before the stream, talk to me at any other time in the stream.
That's inconveniently
stupid. Like,
it'll take you like a second. Your voice does funny things sometimes.
I enjoy it a lot. Okay. If only you listened to it. True, true.
Oh, we were so close to finishing. No, hold on. It's specifically
the like this one. Hold on.
Beat you into a coma, then start tearing your skin off alive
to eat you. subhuman weak stupid like you deserve to die screaming
with black hands be eating your stupid skull until you piss yourself
and start seizing. No one is going to save you. Just I I gotta
go back. Eating your stupid skull and start seizing. No one is
going to save you. Like like this is the face when it when it
ends. Okay, that that's a really nice selection of 12 things
of people insulting you. I feel like I probably get that much
a day. It literally was no there was no like oh hey uh that's
really I disavow that. There's no disavow at all. He's just like,
I get worse than that. And then he did not post anything even
close to that unhinged message, right? Like literally nothing
was close to that. Considering he campaigned against forethought
for similar types of things about I feel like you should at least
do a little quick disavow in there. You you understand that you
were you wait Kelly Kelly. You understand that he did not give
a about those messages, right? I mean, sure, it's more like the
convenience, right, of the argument to give it a full thought.
Yes. Yeah. But at the end of the day, we all ran to get rid of
forethought, so it was fine. I guess that was a mistake. I was
thinking about that today. I understand forethought was unhinged
towards you. I think as a person, I should admit to myself that
I could have been nicer to forthought. I could have cut that
whole thing off before we ever became like enemies of any kind.
It was just cringe. I could have I could have just been like,
"Hey, let's reset." And I didn't do that. So, you know what?
Supposed to have done to stop him from randomly saying the stuff
he did. I didn't say you could you I didn't say you guys could
fix it. I said I could have fixed. Okay. So, you could you could
just ignore all the stuff you said to me then that's fine. I
think I think if I think if I hadn't let it you're talking about
like Kelly being and her but escalated on stream. That's fine.
We can just be homies on the download. Sorry. Let me let Kelly
speak. Are you saying? Let me just let Kelly speak. Can I go
now? God.
You should sit in the corner and think about what you're going
to say before you say it cuz I know it's going to be I don't
want to hear it. I was No, I was going to say that I think probably
the escalation by me on stream in a lot of the cases probably
led to him hating not just me but you even more and led to that
place where he he was making comments like that. I just don't
know if that ever would have happened in the same way if uh if
it hadn't escalated on the stream. I actually I thought about
that like earlier today unironically. I forget why I thought
about it, but I was like, "Oh, yeah. I probably could have made
that not happen." I don't know why you're taking responsibility
for how a fully grown man behaved, but I didn't take responsibility
for it. I said that I think I could have changed the direction
of that whole relationship pretty easily on my end. Uh it might
not have fixed anything with you and I might still have blown
up with him completely because of how he treated you. That's
entirely entirely possible. But I'm saying that I didn't make
any effort on my end and that's probably a personal failing.
No, the sequence of events is not a personal failing. Like there
are c there are sequence of events like if I didn't go to this
certain street, I wouldn't have got mugged. If I didn't go in
this direction towards this place or go by this person, I wouldn't
have goted. But those are not things you can foresee. So they're
not things you can in like hindsight take responsibility for.
Uh maybe in some cases I there's just something there that I
am taking responsibility for and I it might not have changed
anything with you and it might not have changed that situation
and I'm sure if he said those things I actually still would have
kind of lost it on him in any case. But if you had the slightest
inclination he could say those things then I would agree but
I think it was a surprise to everyone that he was that bad. So
I don't think you could have really done much about it because
the first time that someone snaps you can't really like predict
it can you? Some people just don't because they're not fundamentally
deranged. I don't I don't know what it is that makes some people
go that additional step further that other people know not to.
I couldn't tell you. Yeah. Okay. On my Oh, sorry. We Sorry. I
was just like probably you should disavow the comments. Like
maybe maybe he has an editor and he uh maybe like the editor
was like, "Oh, there's a couple messages here and the editor
didn't know and Dan didn't edit this himself and Dan like made
these comments and didn't read the content of the messages or
listen." But I feel like after the I hope a pack of n-words beat
you, you beat you again you eat you. Yeah, I hope that happens
to you. I feel like Dan could have been like, "Whoa, that's a
little bit much." Probably maybe not. Little quick disavow wouldn't
have hurt. little quick one wouldn't have been too bad, but you're
obviously you're very much sensationalizing all of that stuff.
So that's that's why it's happening to you. I'm sorry we're rambling
a little bit here, but I hope that this is helping to understand
what's going on for you. How would you feel if you face this?
There is a very very I'm sorry. There's a fantastic video here
reordering some of these segments. Okay, you put that statement
you put that statement at the end of the unhinged emails. Okay,
obviously you're very much sensationalizing all of that stuff.
So that's that's why it's happening to you. I'm sorry we're rambling
a little bit here, but I hope that this is helping to understand
what's going on for you. How would you feel if you That's a that's
a killer clip right there. Let's go. Face this every day for
more than a year just for doing your job and for daring to push
back against people who hate you for it. You guys are getting
paid. Anyways, that's it. I don't know. I just wanted to cover
this pretty quickly. I don't know how quick this is. It's probably
like a 10-minute video or something, but that's it. just woke
up, saw this, and it's just the the entitlement and the I can't
believe that that I am getting criticized. It's like I don't
So, is the Dan video worth watching? I think so. Anyway, good
night. Okay, good night, Sil. Thanks for coming around. It was
worth watching, but I I didn't expect this is kind of a layup
video, and I think Dan Dan kind of it up. I don't need to make
these arguments that hard, but there's a little bit here where
he's like, I can't believe your victimization. And he's like,
this is nothing compared to the messages I get. I'm sorry. There's
a little So maybe more than one person victimizing themselves
slightly here. I don't know. Yeah, you're kind of a bad person.
What do you want me to say? Me too, by the way. Hey, also guilty.
All right, that's it. Until next time. Cheers. You know what?
There it is. There it is. There we're all bad. And to uh ask
answer question, Kelly, what made you attack Steven's girlfriend?
Are you sure Destiny has a girlfriend? Would be my answer to
that. Okay. All right. Where are we going next? We watched the
Asmin Gold response. I think that's it for the Alysa Marante
stuff. We could probably get back to Amaranth stuff. I don't
know. I don't know when the plan would be to talk to Nick at
some point. Maybe tomorrow maybe we could set something up. We'll
have to see. Oh Jesus. Oh my god. I didn't hear about this. Oh
boy. There's um So what happened here? It looks like there was
an IVF clinic that got bombed in Palm Springs. Okay. And there's
like an there's like a skitso. There's like a skits who posted
their own manifesto as an audio thing. He bombed it. Bombed from
the ground. Jesus. Okay. What did he do? Just waddle. How do
you think? Have you never Kelly Have you never seen like the
explosive vest concept? That's like most how he would just in
with a bomb like that. They probably don't have like bomber I
associate. No bomber associate with someone who's in a bomber
like an airplane and drives are what you're thinking of. Yeah.
Yes. Did you know Japan engineered planes for that? I see. Yeah.
Depended on I'm not incorrect on that. Right. They made planes
that were literally like like they had drones but the drones
had people in them. I'm pretty sure that's a thing. They like
engineered these kind of like things and they just Yeah. They
just like drive the things into people. Yeah. That was crazy.
Very strange. That's not even like top 10 of the weirdest things
they did. Very crazy. Like people think it was just them when
they realized they were going to lose like kamicaziing their
their like nice jets into the Not really. No, Germany did it,
too. They did it better, too. Oh, cool. Okay. All right. Anyway,
it was because you they just botted you in. What? Hold on. What's
salvation salvation saying? Hold on. Oh, God. Salvation. Salvation.
That